news daily from science mission cancers
show drug resistance to small molecule
inhibitors of pi3 kinase and in some
cases make them more aggressive but the
mechanism is unclear authors in the
journal PNAS show that tumors traffic
energetically active mitochondria near
the nucleus to the subcellular margin
sites of cell motility where they
provide a potent regional energy source
to support tumor cell invasion they also
showed that blocking mitochondrial
function reduces tumor aggressiveness
next others in the journal penis report
that clock gene levels in dorsal and
ventral suprachiasmatic nucleus regions
from the long day group of mice we're
out of phase while those from short date
group were synchronized they show that
longer neurons are excited by GABA and
chloride levels were high in these
neurons blocking gaba and chloride pump
the large phase gap seen in long day
group disappear and the cycles of clock
gene levels came to resemble those of
short day group indicating role for gaba
and chloride in maintaining seasonal
changes for more news visitors at www
science mission kamo science mission
facebook page